we're on our way to the purses
it is 550
by 6:00 this has been my dream I really
hope that I get on and win times my
cliffhanger goes something like this
hey old lady they already owe ready brie
oh yeah I'm ready
hungry pretty Jen yeah we gotta walk
faster let's go 100 feet sir
a Rowland 7 o'clock right now we're at
IHOP and there was too many people
online so we have to get tickets for the
four o'clock showing I'm awful sorry now
I'm so tired
desert you will see some pancakes we're
Hollywood Thailand you're still killing
time we've said that how many more hours
the price
come on five more hours kills we came
here we're also gonna go see a movie
all of our stuff could I take picture
we're still waging other prices right
all right take a nap now ten o'clock I
just slept in my car fell asleep we all
slept I'm exhausted
found in The Price is Right
okay the time is not 12 o'clock I still
haven't made as the price is right yet
we just want to see funny people and we
had to leave because it's a two hour
chef's let the price is right I can't
tell you anything about the show the
only thing that I can tell you is that
the gars on November 5th and I promise
you it's a good show so you have to
watch it Oh
why you don't video blog
okay o'clock later no Joey you know how
it hit everybody
you